if you don't change your behaviors
you're going to keep getting what you've
been getting back during the uh pandemic
I ate every dut in a 50-m radius
everything I could eat and I got just
plain fat and I looked in the mirror I
thought this is ridiculous I've got to
stop stress eating or I'm just going to
explode I got to change something I got
to change what I'm putting into my face
all the time and my little app says that
1371 days I have walked or ran 1 to 5
miles every morning rain or shine I'm
out there but I'm 37 lbs down because of
that 1371 days of a permanent Behavior
change because I am now a person that
walks every morning 30 years of helping
people get out of debt and build wealth
personal finance is very similar 80%
behavior and 20% head knowledge it turns
out that the mathematics of wealth
building is about the sixth grade level
you can do it so my question is what's
keeping you stuck